hi everyone it's jerry
let's have a look at a game from the
1962 varna olympiad final
on the wide end wolfgang unzicker and
he's paired against bobby fischer
when i initially skimmed through this
game i was drawn to
the d5 square in the big battle that
surrounds it
d5 is the key weakness in this game in
inherited weakness whenever black ops
for the sicilian nightdorf
as i dove deeper into this 26 move
encounter
many positional ideas surfaced
there are plenty of example games out
there that draw our attention
to a good knight versus bad bishop a
strongly placed white knight on d5
versus a bad bishop i think this game
does a good job
in supplementing those games contrasting
those games and drawing a student's
attention to a key element
in chess namely time
so let's hop right to it as mentioned we
have a sicilian
an open sicilian nydorf
bishop e2 and e5 sure enough
giving the central knight a boot has to
go to a less than desirable square b3
it is and that e5 move has created the
big gap
on d5 it's now a hole so black needs to
take some care
over it bishop e6
point some pieces there be prepared to
knock out
an enemy piece should it arrive there
same sides castles like castles here
we're going to have a same sides castles
game
what do we do with the queen knight well
the queen knight also helps out in
controlling d5
indirectly in this case in case white is
excited
about knocking out the king knight the
queen knight's ready to recapture and
voila d5 is defended directly
move nine f4 how
should you react to this move
uh i think this is a good moment to
throw a pop quiz your way
moment of tension how do you respond
here black to move
what would you play feel free to pause
the video
okay in the game we have queen c7
uh if you simply play bishop to e7 and
say to yourself i just want a castle
it's the opening we're supposed to
castle
not a good decision you will be forced
into
making a positional concession
if bishop e7 was played white can follow
with f5
and black would be forced to do what
give up their good bishop black would be
forced to give up his good bishop for
white's worst peace
the knight on b3 and in the process help
the rook
give white the bishop pair strengthen
white's control over d5
there's just positional concessions all
over the place
if black is forced into capturing the
knight on b3
as soon as the knight went to b3 i could
have noted that
the knight on b3 is white's worst piece
so some other consideration here
some of you may have been considering
the capture on f4 at least you don't
have to worry about your bishop getting
kicked
an issue with that it's not as bad as
bishop to e7 but an issue with the
capture on f4
is that you're no longer controlling d4
so this knight's eyes at least open up
has some prospects d4
maybe even be more invasive on f5
what might we say in short queen c7 is
aimed at
making sure the b3 knight remains
a poor piece does not want to allow that
knight to
quickly contribute in this game
after queen c7 f5 hits
bishop c4 the point behind queen c7
support
bishop c4 move
black is uh
this is the good bishop this is the bad
bishop their intention with one another
but the poor decision
would be would have been to capture the
knight
okay a4
preventing this b5 move from hitting
right away
also maybe clamping down on this
structure
okay bishop e7 only now both queen
both dark square bishops in the ball
game king side castles
and a critical moment here is this move
13. this game could go
in two different directions one is
more positional which is what we observe
in this game more
attention to the queen side of the board
and another is some caveman-like attack
now in the game a5 is played
the structure can change the the
character of the
game can change if white decides to go
with g4 and i want to at least
give a little insight uh with
this variation how should black be
prepared to meet
this move g4 uh right now
white's ready to scare the knight away
so how do we deal with that we could
play h6 that's a fine move first
uh as black we were really wouldn't be
concerned with
the pawn getting there right away and
the bishop recapturing
uh it's a pawn being maintained on g5
attacking the knight that would be
concerning to black the knight doesn't
necessarily have to go anywhere right
now
f6 is very secure
so let's just say white persists
and tries to establish a pawn on g4 how
are we reacting to this
caveman like attack white has basically
gone all in
g4 is the all-in move uh well what do we
do
we react in the center it's a flank
attack
the king is without pawn shelter let's
open up lines d5
is the thematic pawn break to shoot for
even if it costs a pawn to open lines
towards the enemy king the white king
it's the right way forward you don't
have to necessarily calculate
exact lines right away just know that
you cannot afford
as black here to have g5 hit and simply
go back
in reverse the position is opening up if
you're running in reverse like this
big big problems are going to surface
so you have to react energetically d5
would be the way
should this assault occur on the king
side
okay totally different path in this game
more positional
turns towards the queen side a5 hits
b5 a takes b on poisson
knight takes b bishop takes knight
notice
this variation is only possible playing
as black
because the king is on g1 not h1
notice after the capture on v6 it's with
check
otherwise uh white would if the king was
on
h1 white is playing bishop takes bishop
right now
king h1 and now a cool
move i really like this next decision by
fisher
uh yeah okay this next move is
bishop to b5
maintaining the tension uh you take me
i'm not gonna help your queen out you
know i'm not gonna initiate this
exchange connect rooks
queen is maybe slightly improved on e2
nope just backing off
you know at the beginning of the video i
was pointing out
you know my attention immediately drawn
in this game to the d5 square
well let's let's check out this a pawn
if we would just take a couple steps
back here
as soon as this capture came about this
guy right here on a6 is isolated
and you know the rook is on a half open
file
with bishop to b5 black is basically
saying no you take me i want my a pawn
to become a b
pawn and then my b pawn is going to
scare away your knight on c3 which
for right now is a very stable piece
white initiates the exchange is fine
with
uh converting the a pawn to a b pawn
considered to be a bit more uh you know
white can put up a bit more resistance
here
by maintaining the tension playing
bishop d3 queen to e2
but he goes for the exchange he's okay
with the
a file being completely opened
the knight jumps in i believe it would
have been maybe scared away soon
maybe even queen to c7 could be played
and then
uh eventually maybe
white isn't able to maintain a piece on
d5 so
the knight jumps in right away knight
takes knight
queen takes now this is a very strongly
placed queen
and there is now a giant threat here
on a8 um
cool move here as well rook to a4
these are very tiny i mean this is only
a 26 move game these
these little positional ideas
are beginning to add up this a pawn has
been converted into a b
pawn this rook a4 move is saying no
once more you take me help me to maybe
improve my pawn a rank further and
potentially target your b pawn right
after rook to a4 if you're capturing
as white the knight is going to be
kicked away and the b pawn will be
grabbed
and that pawn can fly be passed
so you can't take the rook it's an
excellent pivot square
made possible because of the earlier
decision right bishop to b5
white took recapture we have a wonderful
pivot this
is an excellent excellent pivot square
on a4
also this position right here
when i went through this game a question
came about
for me uh who's
who's bad some something i noted here is
black has a bad bishop
that's true right just the definition of
a bad bishop
you know pawns fixed in the center
primarily
bishop on the same color okay this is a
bad bishop
there are there are active bad bishops
and such okay this is a bad bishop but
what about the it's
uh the white knight let's observe the
minor pieces
this is a bad bishop right here on e7
what about the knight on b3
the structure for white is
it's there for a knight to
get to d5 right if if
only let's just say the knight can get
to d5
white would be winning but
does white have the time to get the
knight there white doesn't have the time
the knight on b3 is four or five tempe
away from getting the d5 square and
that's four
five tempe too many in this half
open uh position black will be able to
put pressure on the a
file subject the the queen side pawns to
some pressure
be able to give direction to to white
it's not so easy to just make four
five consecutive night moves to try and
get into the d5 square it's just not
happening
so what might we say in short
these two guys are both bad
and if we threw both of them under a
microscope
and asked ourselves which of the two
is worse i'd have to go with the knight
on b3
uh why do i think this well the bishop
on e7 is at least fulfilling a
productive role
what's that rule well it's defending uh
this base point this backward pawn on e7
it's supporting black's center
the knight on b3 what are you doing
has no good forward moves is not
fulfilling any productive role
staring off into space knight it's not
doing anything
okay let's see how play follows after
rook a4 we have
c3 queen a6
knight can't even move now unless this
tension is resolved
how do you resolve it if you're
capturing whoa
queen's eyes are opened up the knight
has to find a new home there's going to
be a ready-made target along the half
open b
file okay that's
probably not a wise choice uh you could
maybe concede control over the a file
but uh there's gonna be this pawn break
happening soon c3 is gonna have some
pressure maybe rook to a2
there's a lot of ways black can be
putting pressure on
the queen side pawns what is white's
decision here after queen a6
light goes with h3
this was the other uh positional
idea that surfaced for me in this game
this game
uh i really didn't expect to
i'm not sure how to say it um i'm not
not quite sure
i i didn't really expect to
learn or maybe come up with some kind of
general principle or at least have in
the back of my mind
uh what i consider to be potentially a
nice
general principle but i'd like to share
it with you
um and
it kind of goes like this um
when one side is working with
two pawns and two pawns alone as
shelter for their king something that i
questioned for myself
was which color bishop is
more annoying when we have this
situation right
a rook pawn in a knight pawn as the
king's shelter
right the the the bishop on has gone
elsewhere it's drifted away
which color bishop is going to be the
more annoying
i believe it's going to be the dark
square bishop
and i think this in position types
where major pieces are present
all major pieces are still present in
this case
uh why do i think it's the dark square
bishop that is the more
annoying uh when
there's just these two pawns around well
it's because when you make the most
uh common type of flight square the move
played in this game h3
you're producing a a dark square as a
flight square and this guy could still
control it
and if you were to say go with g3
the bishop doesn't really you know
you're taking into account the bishop
but at the same time you'd be what
you would be subjecting your king to
potentially being cut off along the
second
or seventh ranks um
so that's why i said when you're working
with just
two pawns as shelter for your king and
there are
major pieces present anyhow i'm not sure
how great a general principle it is but
i'm just it's just something i'm
thinking to myself i think it's the
uh dark square bishop that's going to be
the more annoying
for the side who's working with only two
pawns as shelter for their king
basically the bishop that can control
king's
rook ii if you if you could have the the
bishop that controls the king rook
2 kingsrook 2 square i think that's
going to be the more annoying one
when there are major pieces present
okay i know that's a mouthful i know
it's very
you know probably not super clear but
it's something that's kind of for me now
from this point on is a little bit in
the you know the back of my mind
because of this game anyhow i thought
i'd share
from here what do we have h3
rook to c8 oh by the way i think cons
considered
best is in fact g3
um one of the safest squares i think
for the king is not h2
or g2 but rather
may seem odd but the h3 square is maybe
one of the safest squares for the king
go to g2 if you're at some point
you know if there's a check here maybe
you go over to h3 this is likely in
in situations where the queens are still
around
um and it's something to keep in mind it
seems maybe a little bit crazy but that
might be one of the safer squares for
the king
one of the the safer constructions to go
forward with has
white h2 and g3 with these pieces
remaining
okay queen a6 h3
rook c8 all pieces functioning for black
only one for white a queen she looks so
beautiful right there in the center it's
tough to even challenge her
but all the other pieces
not really doing anything okay
rick to e1 easy decision for black
a light square is a flight square much
easier working with these three pawns
right as the shelter
okay king h2 and now the bishop
doesn't necessarily have to be mr
defender right the queen on a6 defends
black is trying to provoke more
weaknesses bishop f4 nearby
white plays g3 and there we go
the second rank is exposed so now
invasion time
rook 8 or excuse me first queen a7
eyeing up queen f2
king scoots over to defend but now rook
a2
big problems what are we doing rook
takes a
rick takes b2 with check
not really good solution here and if you
take the rook the queen enters and still
how we defending this
seems natural enough but now this is
it's unprotected it was unprotected on
e1 but now it's more vulnerable
it's pinned could take on c3
so what am i getting at taking on e2
does not
taking on a2 does not solve white's
problems there is no good
solve here what is tried is king f1
getting out of the pin
but still that earlier variation where i
put on rook takes c3 that also surfaces
right here right now and is the final
move of the game
after rick takes c3 white resigns
take the rook you're getting made it on
f2
and suppose in this position white takes
on
a2 first black would be able to insert
this check
two moves if you go to g2 it would
result in a mate and three
like that and if you went towards the
center
well that's never really going to end
well you don't even have to give mate
right away you could simply get the
material back
and say what are you doing king these
three pieces are swarming in
checks here maybe grab a pawn there
no good solution here it's reading as a
minus
minus 11 minus 12 in stock fish 13's
eyes and
growing okay we don't need to go any
further
than that it's the
it's the move that breaks white right
here rook takes c3
game over so many positional ideas
uh to take away from this one it started
out
again for me the d5 square the whole
controlling it um
making the correct earlier decision
right this queen to c7 move
instead of maybe bishop to e7 taking
into account
how exactly to to react to the f5 move
we don't want to be taking that knight
on b3 look at how
this knight was a an absolutely terrible
piece the whole game
it's because of those earlier decisions
queen to c7
not being forced into bishop takes
knight black played against the knight
on b3 the knight on b3 was the worst
minor piece
these positional ideas really did add up
the backing up with the bishop
right recaps converting the a pawn to a
b pawn
pivoting on a4 forming a battery on the
a
file all these positional factors
eventually
allowed for this uh sacrifice to surface
this little
break down of the the white position
and uh yeah the the take away for me
with this uh two pawns and the what
color bishop is the more annoying
and it's just something that um it's
very rough for me right now
uh it's a rough thought for me right now
but something that's in the back of my
mind
and maybe maybe it is for you as well
anyhow as usual
i hope you got something out of this
video feel free to leave any comments
in the comment section below and
i hope you're having a good day that's
all for now take care
bye
you